Find the perimeter of a
rectangle with the length and
width given below.
Express your answer as
a simplified rational
expression, and state
the domain.
All right, so they give us the
length-- the length is this
rational expression, and the
width is that right there.
If we just draw ourselves
a rectangle-- let's draw
ourselves a rectangle up
here, so we don't use
valuable real estate.
If that's the width, and that
is the length, the perimeter
of this rectangle is going to
be the width plus the length
times 2, because you have two
widths right here, and you
have two lengths.
So you could view that as w plus
w plus l plus l, which is
the same thing as 2w plus 2l,
which is the same thing as 2
times the width plus
the length.
So, we have to find out what two
times the width plus the
length is as a rational
expression, so
let's write that down.
The perimeter is going to be
equal to 2 times the width
plus the length, or we could say
the length plus the width,
either way.
So the width is x minus 3y over
x plus 4, and then the
length is plus 2x plus
5y over x plus 4.
Let's add these two rational
expressions: we have the same
denominator, so we can just
add the numerators.
So this is going to be equal to
2 times-- the denominator
is going to be x plus 4, and we
have the same denominator.
This problem wasn't too hairy,
we didn't have to come up with
a common denominator.
We're going to have x minus
3y plus 2x plus 5y in the
numerator, so let's
just simplify.
We have our x terms-- you have
an x plus a 2x, so that's
going to give us a 3x in the
numerator, and then you have a
negative 3x, and a 5y
in the numerator.
Negative 3 plus 5 is plus
2y in the numerator.
And then we can multiply out
this 2-- we can distribute
this 2, and then we end up with,
we have 2 times 3x is
6x, 2 times 2y is 4y plus 4y,
all of that over x plus 4.
And there's really no way to
simplify this anymore-- here,
we actually had the 2 factored
out, and 3x plus 2y, no common
factors, it's not going to
cancel with x plus 4.
And when they say state the
domain, we just have to think
about the x values that aren't
part of the domain, that would
make either of these
expressions, or this final
expression, undefined.
Actually, all they care about
is the final expression.
And the thing that would make
the final expression undefined
is if this denominator is
equal to 0, and the
denominator is going to be equal
to zero when x is equal
to negative 4.
So we can just constrain the
domain and say x cannot be
equal to negative 4, that we are
not defining, that this is
undefined at x equals
negative 4.
So the simplified, rational
expression for perimeter: 6x
plus 4y over x plus 4.
x cannot be negative 4.